okay will for people who are joining us
on the live stream is actually a little
bit of a different meeting from many
that we've had in our series here this
is a status meeting for machine learning
um which will talk about various things
we're developing so let's launch okay so
first thing we have here is this whole
business about formats for machine
learning and I guess the the winner
seems to be of things that we're going
to develop in the future is o N and X is
it pronounced Oh N and X or is it
pronounced onyx or something
I've no idea actually let's pronounce it
onyx it sounds cool um but so that's
being built deeply into MX net is that
true
so MXN has yet has full support to that
and Amazon is one of the major sponsors
now of this format and then also PI
torch Cafe - and Microsoft's ent case
for turds they were the original ones
that that wished us and how faithful is
the representation of a typical neuron
that in this format
so the one one thing that it's quite
different philosophies does that
encoders don't get attached to this
right right it's the wrong network right
so our own WL net contains the encoders
yeah the UM okay so we had a project to
make a protocol buffer some kind of
protocol buffer IO system like two years
ago
do you know what happened to that
I asked on the new epic of meaning lists
and I think much was yes at home were
Kim Jones and I'd will respond to that I
don't think this they mentioned any
previous weaponless okay so I suggest
you ask got a node and Garrett yeah I
was certainly a project that was in the
list I don't know where the stuff was
done art but you know and the channel
framework folk like ego Bakshi I mean
this is an alternative to the channel
framework is that true how should I
think about protocol buffers it's nicer
it's similar to like Jason yeah so it's
basically designed to be like JSON but
much more efficient because he can
binarize it okay okay well fair enough
so that will turn into an import/export
format is that correct it's a little bit
more subtle than that because when you
when you parse data from an external
source when you produce the sort of
binary on the wire format as it's called
you do that relative to a a sort of
definition which is called a proto proto
file so it combines these two things in
a way that I don't think is a
particularly good fit for the import and
export why do you say that I mean like
binary read lists or something has a way
of specifying the structure of the thing
you're reading you know an int followed
by two you know Long's or whatever it is
right as it absolutely take a look at it
as far as I remember it's missing the
kind of recursive stuff like for example
an arbitrary list that's delimited by
something or read the length and then
yes it's missing I mean that would be
more like delimited array and so on in
other words that would be this is the
type specification you know I hate these
documentation things where they point
you to another piece of documentation we
really should flatten those out um okay
so here your point is that you can't say
that's that's correct right but we
perfectly well could turn this into a
grammar
mm-hmm and and indeed like interpreters
is already generated a lot of that
grammar right
so I mean if that's what you're talking
about I don't think that's incompatible
and shoddy maybe you can say something
about this with the kind of design we
have for import-export stuff all right
anyway so let's figure out what what's
that file for these protocol buffers and
then there's the actual okay read
according to that template file in
protocol buffer format sure but do we
have an examples of important export
weights parameterised in that way there
is no pretty both I think that's I think
there is I mean I think there are things
were trying to remember here maybe shadi
maybe you can comment on this doesn't
doesn't aren't there things where you
basically are giving in the elements
specification you're giving a structure
though is what you should read
not really no not a structure we do have
partial access in a lot of the formats
but not a structure specification all
right well so maybe this is I mean maybe
it's something slightly new but it's
similar to minor II read lists I think
you know what why don't you get more
detail and then let's do a design
discussion about it
yes Tully honestly I think yeah honestly
it's a fairly big project I don't to to
to do it well and expose it to users so
you know do it without exposing it to
users I would prefer to do that first
and we sort of gather a bit of
experience with that especially it's it
fine okay let's keep going here ah GPUs
GPUs etc um okay new models cool can we
see them
let's take a look how about the neuron
that repository doing so we've actually
not ripped the post yes so we still have
noticed that it's load wrong that loaded
like that I think if I reload it'll come
out okay but the first load was wrong
that's weird
okay so what am I looking at here so
there's new neural nuts
7 new mod if you scroll all the way to
the bottom and just click on the all
resources there are 3 new I'm not sure
how to pronounce it Adam except ok
there's 3 dilated resident why don't we
stop putting dates on these seems to me
we should start you know so we can have
sort by date here well maybe I think by
recency is good but like do we yeah the
day it seemed like they might fetcher it
quite a lot
I don't know well we don't certainly
have to put the date everywhere but in
this I think certainly in the in the
actual shingle here we should put the
date all of them to start with like what
when they were either developed or
released so in the we should say when
they were added to our thing because I
think it's very unembarrassed soon to
distinguish between submission date to
the repo and release date of the model
yeah what I want to talk about is
release date on the reef on the repo we
do have that information within the
resource object but it could be we could
have a service on the actual website
yeah let's surface it say browse by
recency yeah where should it go
should just go like maybe just
underneath uh at the very end at the end
Roy not yes requirements okay or above
all right so I think I think it should
be look at how it's done elsewhere in
demonstrations we just added a date
thing you know even though
demonstrations go back ten years we
haven't been putting that those dates on
make sense so do it the same way it's
time for demonstrations and there's a
new format demonstrations that was
recently added thanks sure
oh okay so briefly about the resource
object why do we show that sometimes a
lot of the times do we shoot okay yeah
okay so what all these what all these
new networks six of them are semantic
segmentation caps net is classification
it's like Lynette but it kept some
different oh it's the modern capsule
Network thingy dingy yeah and the deep
speech one is up there too what is that
I see that's the name so that is an that
is an on compiled law MX net thing you
know it's a placeholder until early
supporters in the next word but by the
way if I might say so it seems foolish
to have the thing that is the most
obscure be the most bright in the well
the original the original goal of that
was to make sure people didn't
accidentally deploy them to the new life
repository which is a he was expecting
what we deliberately
why don't we why don't we make that
color like our standard pink color sure
that's ridiculously bright you know I
mean I understand it's a warning but
it's also an emphasis so this works is
that right and what does it look like if
I were to okay here we go so so you're
saying if I run this right now um
and why is this not loading in oh there
we go
is it big
is it big oh it's only such two
megabytes why is it loading so damn
slowly
not sure now their packet updated in the
background I noticed that was one of our
faith what an earth is this what we
could hide the guts of the function that
we not I don't think we need to hide the
we don't we just have it raw rather than
having all kinds of back to key things
oh sure yeah like the wrong code yeah
well I mean that is how the code would
look if you got it out on in the
notebook I understand why don't we at
least have it with the can do a
four-minute version of the code
yeah something a little bit nicer than
that but maybe with a background color
to indicate that it's that it's not
yeah what about it sorry Jenny we're
gonna say something no I was a bit
scared by seeing some new networks
backtick privates like this one be
backward compatible so documented this
shouldn't be here at all it will be gone
in the next version so just so I don't
think we should display it and it should
be right what's going to happen to this
net model in the next version
there's yes basic what happens is that
we have versions for content elements
for resource objects and some of you
have a version too okay fine that'll be
automatically downloaded yeah cool okay
well then what's funny is it for
training you don't need this custom
layer that's only for the evaluation
part so training is perfectly all right
so we're practicing this and it will be
fixed
weathering again yeah do you put already
the fine text for Lancer Network no that
hasn't gone up yet okay it doesn't have
a page yet right no I mean it's it's non
discoverable right now
[Music]
that was not limited to one - I think so
- yeah oh yeah definitely if we're ready
to submit it it can be submitted and we
can I just basically need an example
notebook and a construction notebook for
it and then we can publish it on the
repo okay what's that that's a Jerome
issue I mean she wrote that very nice
blog post about it surely he has that
stuff and also we should point by the
way that's something I'm not sure if
we're doing that Megan is point to
Jerome's blog post when it comes to
discussing that network right the
shingle should point to his blog post so
the reason we didn't actually put this
on for now is that it requires a lot of
MX layers and we're not sure if we
actually represent those in the future
which means that this network might
break in the future because M excellent
MX layer might change so we've been
worried about that I don't know
experimental functions we have
experimental networks
it's possibility okay we'll think about
that Jan okay let's move on here polish
the yellow - network is that related
damage cases yes is we we weren't part
of it on the repository as soon as
possible okay but we it was exposing
some internal stuff so we material
helped me like rewriting some some
layers to avoid some internal options so
it's it's now it will be better on the
on the repo so ten levels in the SQL q
what is the sequence here is that
there's a she I was wrong about that I
thought the segmentation models or not
whistle in the queue but they've
actually made it to the front row Megan
what is the process here do you send the
stuff through sqa or are you sending
who's doing QA on these things and what
are the continuing tests that have
maintained I send it through DQ a so I
get a submission I approve it I put it
all together and make the internal
shingle I send it through D what's the
actual s QA aspect of this I mean we
should be testing every every thing in
the repository should be tested like
when we get to
and 11.3 right the next equation I mean
these should because generated for these
things exactly is this list of things to
do with QA is to have proper test I mean
I think Megan and you should play talk
to Raj and figure out how one gets a
systematic testing process for these
shows actually as we've had so we've
been in discussions Raj to revamp the
entire testing procedure as well because
at the moment there's no testing that
happens on GPUs automatically oh gosh
but this is I Kelly there's a custom
running how many GPU variants although
that we have to test on I don't think
that's the major thing I think we low
memory one and a big memory one until
Intel and AMD really the solution what
about things where people can have
different versions of libraries install
the Cameo or is that not I mean
different revs of the Intel chip certain
things did they allow different
libraries well we ship the the CUDA so
we there's no variance there there is
graphics drivers versions this is an
operating systems that was a potential
thing like it might work and window has
been honestly that we do those tests we
do anyway except the thing we're not
doing is that matrix going across
different GPU configurations I think I
mean I don't know exactly I know we're
doing that by hand I don't think that's
part of the automated exactly so that's
what we're setting up now so we're
getting GP machines into the automated
testing okay okay good and yeah this
will we should definitely have a test
for this as well and it has to obviously
test on GPU plus CPU and make sure that
it doesn't change in the future right
okay
data sets what is this thing so
Microsoft's cocoa the there was a new
version released late last year that I'm
working on importing into among the DB
for us that's for internal use for
that's for that okay mmm-hmm what does
the resume
the upload of that's the s3 upload
reward yes is something that we didn't
have time to add before we were like
fixing our things it would be nice if we
could upload the big data set in like
multiple chunks given it sometimes we
have arrows so things like that it's
basically to save Megan time and you
know this instead of like me starting
from the beginning every time okay
images okay now the data so that is a
big data set for image object detection
in images but we should have in you know
[ __ ] Cody's okay so listen we've let's
let's move on here speech recognizer
okay cool
so can you demo this yeah I mean there's
a very the first version of the network
so it did it is very slow but it does
something so okay should we let you
share your screen okay is this using the
fixed beam search by the way sent okay
so this is the signal that hopefully
will not crash and big time could you
hear we more or less okay should have
been no I can see your screen can also
share his audio yeah okay so yes
familiar would anyways its voice that
says yeah okay so I know it is quite
quick because it is cached and I already
waited this what's the value of steps of
the recognition we have first a feature
X to do why don't you do an audio I mean
yeah you're Italian Scottish accent
hello my name is Cavanaugh let's see now
does anything and as I said right now
this is the first version of the network
annual welcome back but no way no way
where's the language model I mean hello
shouldn't have been wrong no the
language model is off by default and
currently we just have this option to
activate it and so there's sort of like
well when we when it's better a little
no more names like a curry hasn't been
trained any names yes that's it okay so
it's tiny anyways it works it does we do
we can do some limited separation of
words and figuring out which at which
time the pronoun this is great I don't
think that's the right way to present
this no this is completely not final
this is just a way to get the results
out to test the network essentially this
is that we know that final output can I
see the network can we see the network
sure if I remember it's probably on the
net free poetry yeah yeah actually do
you have the name handy
yeah I'll tie know the link from the
repo hold on a second okay and you can
test it down on your machine as well
Steve and given it's in the net model
you mean I can actually run it well you
can download the network and there is
some evaluation function that goes with
it there's a web page for it so it's
deep speech to trained on by doing this
data role model so here just type in D
speech you should find us it two words
to us well how is that search working
Megan is that so working decently or not
yes that should be expanded I mean it
really depends on how whether you have
good keywords in there or not okay so
this is why I think so slowly again a
question for Megan do you know why this
download is so slow no ascensions that
it is updating in the it updates if it
finds a new model so I don't know if
that has anything to do it no it was 200
megabytes should be coming in a snap for
with my network there the cloud object
standard there first I think so Megan I
think you should investigate this I
think there's something wrong and that
will be a question for Brad Ashby and
Bob system okay so we're going to say
what's happening here so that okay there
we go
so this is that network and what you're
saying is if I do an audio capture here
no you need the evaluation function the
reason that this called role model is
our current audio and code doesn't
support this thing bit of all for this I
have to have yes exactly
okay so we call it role model because
the final thing will be there later on
hello let's see if the speech
recognition works
all right so yeah there's no language
model let's see if it can do to it okay
um you can just do net evaluative that
holy object
I'm sorry not evaluative what of the
idea object it just requires a little
sense what is already growing somebody
is asking on the livestream what is the
deployment process for models trained in
of malanga age
well it's not bad that's really not bad
um I mean obviously better if there's
language model um the answer for
deployment is you can deploy it in our
cloud or you can deploy it as a roar
IMAX net file but then you don't get all
the nice encoders and all these kinds of
things like you don't get to just take
an audio object and stick it into well
this this isn't so beautiful because it
required code here but soon you'll be
able to just stick it into this neuron
that and have it work um and by the way
you can use a lot of this stuff for free
on the web if you if you're wondering
that um okay but let's so let's talk
about speed here why is it comparatively
slow and what will make it faster
including things in the neural network
itself that will make it faster and what
what we are doing at the moment will
resize as a network in order to take is
the length of the of the audio sample
that you provide every time so the
promise we currently support variable
length for convolutions with padding
layer so this is a feature that we're
currently adding that means that this
thing can't run a durable length so yeah
as Tim says you have to let that code
that evaluation function there's a
resizing operation which is quite
expensive okay but that'll pick on the
future there's other things as well so
things like CPU performance hook up
dramatically in the next version when we
use intel's new purposes we will be able
to segment a speech signal and do a
bunch the valuation of the various
segments that will speed up creation we
do have herbal a convolution we just
don't have double adding that stuff
Pacolet updatable
but yeah in fact I my my ambition is to
add this feature this paddock support
reverberant completions as part of the
bug fix packet update that would be
really preparing for the other issues
which is what on what times go weeks a
week one week okay cool
all right well this looks great I mean
this is starting to work um I'm sorry
what's the story with the language model
what's they so during the decoding
actually what the what the network
outputs it's a probability for each
character and the language model acts as
a separate experts at every frame of the
of the audio signal so the acoustic
experts say I believe this is this
character and language model say well my
feeling given what we saw previously is
more like this and eventually you mix
the two expert to come to the final
decoding okay but I'm asking in terms of
the development process where are we at
with the language model and when when
will we have something that is as good
as it can be so so we already have a
language that was trained on speech
value speech from from TED conferences
and seems like that and we are author
training and on more on larger data sets
so we will great language model as it
goes but but doesn't the language model
only need the text it doesn't need the
speech anymore right yes yes many
trained on Texas told me we can either
have you know written text like
Wikipedia or something we can have
endless transcripts yes that's actually
the data said matters a lot because you
don't speak like Wikipedia so if you are
expert is trying to format everything
like a Wikipedia sentence it homes I
mean probably for the spelling that you
will it can also modifies everybody
talks like a TED talk either
that's a point so where are we going to
get realistic transcripts I mean clearly
you know there are there are gazillions
of like you know from litigation and the
court records there are just
unbelievable
you know amounts of transcripts again
probably not perfectly everyday speech
but that is just running speech what
where are some other sources of
large-scale speech transcripts that
seems like a good one and we certainly
can get there's there's a lot of that
available easily sorry
well yes everything we can we can't we
can add with who is working on that
problem of getting of getting the you
know transcript datasets
I think for most of what's done now it
was I in Celestin okay have you talked
to the curation folk like Alan and so on
about whether they have ideas for where
to get it yeah I would recommend I mean
you know my immediate most obvious look
that they're couple of cases there's
there's things like the closed
captioning from television which we have
a lot of and can get even much more of
and then there's I think things like the
you know federal court system you know
records which will contain I don't know
how you segment off the parts that are
actual transcripts from the parts that
are um you know filed information and so
on I don't know where else there'll be
um and we should think about where else
there is large volumes of transcript
data data I think including a part of
classic written text we can we certainly
have a data set of all presidential
inauguration speeches and things those
are considered ordinary speech but those
are that's this won't be much I guess in
terms of length but I think putting a
piece just to any capillary just to over
right so why don't you ask Alan because
that's his kind of area and see what he
can surface of just transcripts of as
realistic everyday speech as possible
nice to know there's a last aspect that
we need to be done I think the speech to
tag that involves some some design and I
think it's interesting it's the
post-processing so as you see here all
the characters are in the small cap
a-to-z space
yes space and probably we wants to put
dots between sentence yup kumar's case
laters and maybe more importantly I mean
importantly also importantly if I say
$163 maybe we should convert that to you
know the last are 163 numbers yep those
entities like names or places they're
capitalized as well sure I mean what we
have what has happened with our
capitalized function which um I mean
capitalized has some things has various
options but I don't think it has um
let's take a look here yeah yeah so
title case all important tags into in
naturally but right probably be a
function function that he's an inverse
of spoken string really yes yes well
wait a minute what do you mean the
inverse of spoken string name basically
okay so here's one very simple one you
know the person at you know 12
st. James Street right and we want to
turn that into a high entia
oh yeah right in street as well
but anyway but I mean okay fine but I
mean that my point is ultimately we want
to turn it into something like that yeah
yeah yeah that's interesting I mean that
that is a nice machine learning function
I would think that way spoken string of
that what does it do
take a look you know if the second one
or the other okay
you
but you know this is or it doesn't
I don't think it needs to 12 is
speakable but listen this is like
colorize for text
right you take a piece of text and you
just a lowercase everything then you
need to reconstruct the non lowercase
version that's the our colorized
function the text you want to add some
missing parts and you have some
imputation about it's where to point the
punctuation well same thing right so my
point is think about that you just take
a random Wikipedia article for example
right so here's here's my idea for
training right so let's say Wikipedia
data
James whatever that might be um you know
let's get the data here it'll be some
big long thing well let's say let's just
say gosh that's long okay well it wasn't
actually so long because it's some um
James Street if there is one how about
Jane Street that's the name of a hedge
fund I'm sure that'll have something oh
great okay well anyway um who knows okay
it doesn't matter but but but you know
case my point is you just take the data
and you simply lowercase and D punctuate
everything and then you want to learn
back what the capitalization and
punctuation should have been exactly so
it's it's exactly the analog of
colorization for an image yeah except
numbers are the one thing that's
slightly harder but um oh yeah somebody
is suggesting here um
oh yeah it's actually several
suggestions here on the live stream
sports commentaries used as data that's
an interesting one if those are
available in transcript form another
suggestion is speech transcripts from
university classes I don't know I assume
that there are from MOOCs and things
there may be some transcripts well even
if yes that's an interesting idea
and another one which I was sort of
getting at was the transcript of the US
Congress congressional record the person
says they talk like everyday people I
haven't actually listened to it I don't
know um and there's also reddit that's
right
yeah reddit I mean I I guess that's
right I mean these places were people
right like they speak like reddit
so okay that's clearly good some good
sources of you know right like you speak
type text so let's ask the curation team
to try and collect some and let's do
some training on that but I really like
this idea of trying to get you know the
the inverse of just D capitalizing and D
punctuating everything and that seems
like something we should try and do we
know what kind of network we would try
and train for that it's it's typical
sequence to sequence trainings something
close to translation so try it I mean
you can generate immense amounts of
training data for this definitely anyone
attention mechanism that's the main
thing that will make this work well yeah
what do you mean so for the sequence of
signals example the attention mechanism
allows it should basically look back at
the input sequence - right and forth
it's basically copying out something
that right okay wonderful
all right so let's let's talk about um I
just want to skip to the end here and
then I want to come back to the audio
identify stuff
implementing LCC 125 what is that that's
a big new stuff there's a big needle are
you with us yes it is my stuff
what is LCC 125 I normalize and norm
update to argument form was that a
charity case what it is oh okay
I'm sorry I was just totally confused um
oh yeah somebody else on the livestream
is suggesting for for kind of right like
you speak stuff mailing lists for random
open-source projects and so on yeah I
mean look there's there should be a lot
of material here that's right like you
speak stuff okay um okay
you're doing linear algebra stuff here
but you weren't involved Konstantin has
been doing the hash stuff right the new
hash stuff correct
it is it is delayed it's different
project he's not involved in Constantine
University there was a indeed consistent
hash project to do har that is both fast
and it will be the same for all versions
of Pokemon when in the future and but
this who might actually postpone AIDS
because we we think that the world that
Peter is doing with worry is very
important
maybe commemorate Carre's right and so
if you can help in some way like making
mkl function work on Rory
that would be great and that would help
us for machine learning you know since
there's many models that are program
top-level that would be great if they
can use water instead of factory they
would gain you know probably some steed
but most importantly some memory right
okay last topic and we're running over
time I think here is the audio identify
stuff um so there's this saying you have
got an audio identify working color well
I have in training I'm going to figure
out which is the best architecture and
the best type of parameters I have a
couple of architectural style
essentially some equivalent to image
identifiers some equivalent to us net
which some of the adaptation to the
audio domain and they seem to do
something they seem to work fine I mean
so the output is things like dog bark
and so on is that right its ability
class yes go ahead show it okay so well
assuming that things wonderful
everything is
something bad is happening well we put
what is this is the boring part of the
app but this is just the training
progress of the last few things - you
still have the graph that would be no
responsive if you give me a second I
will restart Mathematica and okay have
it working hopefully okay good so let's
talk about the pitch identify stuff so
you also have something which is an
audio pitch identify no I don't have
anything I just I have an architecture
that I am planning to explore a little
bit but given that I have no data sets
that are effective I just used the sound
from Mathematica to generate an audio
signal okay which is really kind of ok
so the issue there is where do we find
play each note on a piano pet play each
pair so there are several issues one
there is no architecture that has been
proven to work there is one paper that
has had good results but only trained on
piano music ok why do I think that why
do we believe what do we believe this
should be operating on a spectrogram or
operating on the actual raw audio signal
well I mean the spectrogram is the most
safe button what most papers use so that
used as feature for the why do we
believe that modern machine learning is
going to be useful relative to classical
signal processing for this well none of
the two approaches has been completely
successful yet so this is just
exploration ok
but for monophonic stuff it can be done
yes for monophonic stuff it can be done
and we do have some functionality to
extract the fundamental frequency so
there is already in the system where is
it in audio local measurements
fundamental frequency
oh I didn't even know that okay and how
does that work
there's classic signal processing just
okay looking I mean just starting to
support the pitch detect function what
is the pitch detect function going to do
so the point is we haven't thought about
design of pitch detect because we don't
know exactly if it will be possible to
have and what will be possible to have
so my plan was to play around with a bit
of neural networks to figure out what we
can get out of it and after that we can
have some designers I mean I really have
to be interesting we would need to be
able to represent musical scores and so
on okay so this is a long-standing
project that hasn't started yet
maybe she'll basic stuff of having of
moving over all the stuff we did a music
theory for wolf alpha moving that over
too often language functionality so we
have had several meetings about this and
Holly do you want to comment about the
status of write both with Mike mentor
and Philip Bloom these seem to be the
people internally that could help a lot
Mike left but grabbing what what is
available and Wolfram Alpha and just
putting it in the language is not going
to work there is a bigger symbolic music
framework that we basically have to
develop in order for us to be able to
really represent music in the correct
way in the language so it is a
substantial new development needed there
and the reason for this is we've got to
be able to take a score basically and
have some appropriate symbolic
representation yeah and the people have
I mean in like finale and things like
that do they have a I mean they have an
XML I know there's ambient music XML but
is it reasonable it seems so
and there are several other approaches
lily pond is a software that generates
we dealt extensively with the lily pond
folks some kind than other ones right
there may be a to go and interaction
with those guys okay
that has any time another presentation
some music library that's called the
music 21 for Python has an also nice
representation of curves so there are
several
systems that we want to analyze you know
that's the plan but then the end result
of that is what we're really trying to
do is ultimately is a music recognize
that will return some kind of symbolic
music object yes so you can do from now
what if this had worked we would have
union and sound out this is the idea
behind um but maybe we should still have
a pitch detect function or something
like that but isn't an obscure piece of
audio measurements that simply you know
given a you know just as a repackaging
of what's the fundamental frequency of
the sound for the simple case okay
because I've seen a bunch of people
wanting that for all kinds of things
that aren't really music related you
know like you you have a you know I
don't know a lathe that's turning at a
certain rate and you just want to listen
for what is the fundamental frequency
okay okay so what would we return
so from pitch detect what we return is
the the best guess of the fundamental
frequency if I if I listen to mains hum
or something from the you know I should
get sixty Hertz
yes measurements we were telling a time
series okay so a reasonable result but
if you really want a sound no I think
the case that we want I mean there are a
couple of different things we might want
we might want the you know we might just
want one number that is you feed in this
thing and you want to know what is the
average pitch of this thing I like I can
see a bunch of use cases where you're
like trying to debug things and you've
got a sound and it's like what is that
is that a 60 Hertz hum is that you know
what is that now I agree though I I
think that the time series case is
actually a more obscure case because
that assumes that's like playing one
note at a time I mean
it's cute but it's more of a novelty
item I think now it could I mean the
assumption is that if the fundamental
frequency changes over time that's why
time series well okay so that's
interesting so I mean okay let's have a
discussion about packaging that whether
it's whether we want the time series
case or the static case is interesting
um but you know I think we should do
that and I think it's a completely
separate thing from worrying about
things like polyphonic music okay
because I mean I think there was already
a lot of utility to that pure pitch
detection thing and noticed that in
terms of training we actually don't want
music there we want it to be trained on
weird machine sounds and so on right in
a signal processing yeah signal
processing it seems reasonably well I
think that'll be the right thing I can't
imagine that machine learning is going
to help with something which is
basically where's that you know
concentration of energy in a spectrogram
basis well it's not necessarily that
easy because I mean sounds do have
plenty of harmonics and we're
essentially does that what about a sound
where the lowest is there is it the case
that one gets situations in which the
lowest like I don't know in period
doubling or something you know where the
lowest frequency is actually not the
dominant frequency yes you do get that
and you didn't get also that the
dominant frequency is not the one with
the highest standard here so you have
plenty well I mean so say you have one
harmonic at 100 Hertz with an amplitude
value of 0.5 and an on and another
harmonic at 200 hats with an amplitude
value of one yeah right because because
of the fact that the the energy depends
on frequency so that but you can have
more energy in a higher harmonic other
than the first mark but it will be
brighter
but so what when somebody is trying to
say you know this there's a rattle in my
airplane or something what is the
frequency of the rattle and won't they
want the well usually harmonic sounds so
the same applies here which means
there's a lowest frequency which is the
true rattle frequency and the higher
ones are just a harmonic of that lowest
frequencies that would just exactly
exactly you want you don't want to find
the lowest frequency you want to find
the minimum frequency of which all
others are multiples of I so to say
claim is that in physical phenomena the
typical cases there is a fundamental
frequency and then a bunch of harmonics
stacked on top of that exactly of those
can be essentially whatever right okay
look I think this is a very useful
function that has absolutely nothing to
do with music transcription okay and I
think we should try to have that um
let's see we had right um okay I think
that is everything somebody asked in the
livestream do train your models in
distributed fashion on cloud machines
yes there and in fact we're using have
we started using these voltar AWS
thingies is that what we're doing right
now not yet
what when do we get to start that
there's the half precision support
wasn't yet finished for the most recent
version but it's high on my list as soon
as I'm done with this bug fixing phase
what is half precision what do you mean
what if the 16 bit support that's that's
the the v-102 tends to cause the kind of
reason to use the voltar cards the whole
point is at 16 bit yeah and it's you
know much faster sounds good
okay anything else from anybody here so
if you want I can share quickly the ID
identify if you have to Moshe yeah okay
driving no go ahead go ahead go ahead go
ahead I'm late for something
okay so I have the two networks trained
used as feature extractors I run them on
our example data that we have in the
layout and this is the corresponding
features play space plot in the two
cages as you can see there is some
semantic separation so although all of
these are signals just impulse responses
flute and flute scales are recognized as
very similar as beyond scale that these
are human or animal sounds these are
musical instruments these are mechanical
things so I mean this is quite good we
can get it as a time function yep just a
comment on this tree structure and it
would be a big boost for classified
predict and yes an immense improvement
of that what we have right now for the
audio case exams really nice and the
other thing I test I tested it on a data
set that has 50 classes that C is
commonly used as a benchmark the human
accuracy on this and the deficit is
about 81% and as you can see with the
feature extractor then classify we do
way better than human accuracy so this
is is it a frog or is it exactly and
this is the feature space plot of data
set various colors are the various
classes and as you can see it manages to
separate various classes quite
effectively it's a spectacular
so it's promising these are the first
tests in terms of training in hyper
parameters but it seems to be promising
it looks very promising when when can we
get that and do we have the ontology
reasonably well cleaned up as has I've
been going through the
our dress is a word of it I need to
speak with him again because that will
be definitely needed to clean up the
results because the classes are
imbalanced so okay that was really neat
it's very nice
okay thank you all very much see y'all
soon